طبعا طبعا المنطقه منطقه الضاحيه الجنوبيه
لبيروت لها دلاله كبيره وهي وهو العنصر
والعامل الاول الذي يطرح في مساله النقاش
الان نحن نتحدث عن منطقه الضاحيه الجنوبيه
لبيروت التي تعتبر معقلا اساسيا لحزب الله
فيها الكثير من المراكز السياسيه والمراكز
الاداريه والقياديه التابعه لحزب الله في
تلك المنطقه هناك الكثير من الشخصيات في
حزب الله تسكن في الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت
الجمهور العريض لحزب الله اذا صح التعبير
يتوزع صحيح في الجنوب اللبناني ولكن ايضا
في الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت وبالتالي كلها
معطيات اساسيه المرحله والتوقيت الذي وقع
فيه هذا الانفجار في خضم هذه المواجهه
المفتوحه اذا صح التعبير في جنوبي لبنان
بين حزب الله من جهه الجيش الاسرائيلي من
جهه وفي ظل التهديدات الاسرائيليه التي
استمعنا اليها في المرحله الماضيه ب حزب
الله على وجه التحديد كلها تطرح علامات
استفهام بشان الحدث الذي وقع الان وطبعا
كل التحقيقات بدات من جانب الجهات الفاعله
في تلك المنطقه وتحديدا حزب الله وايضا من
جانب الجهات الرسميه اللب اللبنانيه كان
من قبل الجيش اللبناني من قبل الادله
الجنائيه لتبيان حقيقه ما حصل هل هو
انفجار ناجم عن عمل امني معين عن عمليه
قصف قد تكون تمت في المرحله الماضيه ام ان
هناك سياره مفخخه مثلا انفجرت في تلك
المنطقه طبعا الان من المكثر جدا الحديث
عن الا باب التي ادت الى هذا الانفجار
ولكن الاكيد ان الانفجار ادى الى اضرار
كبيره في منطقه الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت
وتحديدا منطقه المشرفيه التي نحن نتحدث
عنها هناك اضرار في المساكن في المنازل
السكنيه الموجوده في تلك المنطقه هناك